the Joe Rogan experience I mean I still
get weirded out when I meet famous
people that I really like well but who I
mean there obviously are people who are
you know like Jack Nicholson for example
is way more famous than you but like
there's not many people you're almost
are you a Louise you say your alias no
no no I'm like a c-list person you know
here is B react yeah I don't act I'm not
on TV I'm C list and I'm a cage fighting
commentator you know it's pretty easy to
dismiss me yeah I'm more more c-list I
just a lot of people your age no I am
it's different everybody my age knows
who you are it's different different
world but so the fear factor thing was I
had done a lot of stuff after news radio
that didn't work not a lot of stuff but
a few pilot scripts that I had gotten a
few meetings that I had with people that
were kind of goofy there was a lot of
like and I didn't I loved working with
Mike at mine cast my friends from
Newsradio they were great but I had also
worked with a bunch of actors who were
actors it said it's not an environment
it's not a job that lends itself to
authenticity yeah it's a job that lends
itself to conformity because you're
always auditioning for things so you
want everybody to like you so you sort
of pattern your likes and dislikes your
behavior patterns your your your
opinions to what I you lick your finger
yeah and put it in the air where's the
wind blowing I'm going that way sure the
safest way to make a living and there's
a lot of that in Hollywood I was gonna
say that gets back to my point about how
insular they are now everybody in
Hollywood like yeah Oprah 2020s [ __ ]
great who the [ __ ] is sitting in you
know Kentucky like yeah well I may be
somebody maybe some things are man
struggling with wrestling with menopause
maybe some housewives Falls annexed out
there like so when Fear Factor came
along two things I thought one was gonna
be cancelled immediately I was really
convinced yeah we don't forever forever
148 episodes then we came back and did
seven more but the getting attacked by
dogs and making people eat eating bull
dicks yeah
this is no way this is gonna last it's
crazy and so I felt I felt like at the
very least it would give me some
material and it was it was a generous
amount of money and it was money that
well I was like okay if I do this and I
keep doing this I don't have to do other
things like I can be free and that
having that ability to say no to things
and have fuck-you money
and to just not worry about how to pay
your bills I knew when I lived in New
Rochelle is actually when I got my first
development deal and when I got my first
development deal there was this this
physical wait huh that left lipped
lifted off of me where I didn't have to
worry how am I gonna pay my rent next
yeah how am I gonna pay my gas how many
sure cuz that was a I went from that to
having some money and the feeling that I
got it was like okay this is valuable
this is some [ __ ] idea like having
money I'm not saying like that being
rich makes you happy it's not but having
resources is a valuable thing and having
the resources to not have to do
something you don't want to do and where
you can pursue what you want to do
that's valuable as well so it's funny
you bring that up because I covered a
this study that came out a few weeks ago
on my show and apparently researchers
found out that when you can't you hit a
certain level of happiness when you hit
$75,000 a year because I think they they
figured out that that's where people can
generally pay the bills
yeah and be okay and then they said if
you make up to ninety five thousand you
do see a noticeable increase in
happiness when you jump from 75,000 to
ninety five thousand so that's when
people pretty much across the board or
like okay I'm good and then everything
after that you're playing with house
money mmm so they say you know the
difference between make a ninety five
thousand dollars a year and a million
dollars a year even though there's a big
material difference there in terms of
how much it buys your happiness it
there's a tapering effect when you hit
that ninety five thousand dollar
threshold I think also the amount of
work that you have to do to make a
million dollars a year significant share
dresses you out the you don't have time
to do things that you love like say if
you you know you have some hobbies that
you really enjoy you feel like I got to
leave those alone for a while I got to
pursue my career and go after my career
really make it happen yeah
it's hard to balance that life comfort
appreciation for your just your
existence here and trying to make a
living and yeah sometimes people get
that way wrong and they go all-in on
making a living and then you become some
[ __ ] Harvey Weinstein guy who's just
all about just vices and just filling
your life up with things that try to
make you happy because you've got five
hundred dollars in the bank and you're
constantly working and you just it's not
a good example Harvey Weinstein's like
the example yeah he's a [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] people and what not alleged the
the better example would be someone who
works so they have a heart attack and
then realizes they never had any fun and
now the health is deteriorated so
radically that they they can't have fun
and then they can't work and they can't
even do what they do and then they have
to sort of reboot their life I mean I
just think it's very important to enjoy
your time here it's it's [ __ ]
fleeting like Kevin Smith just had all I
saw that yeah yeah I love that guy he's
a great guy has he ever been on the
podcast yeah a couple times I've been on
his he's been on this one a couple times
he's awesome
he's just a sweet a genuine sweetheart
of a guy he's one of those guys where if
he doesn't like someone I don't like him
oh we trust him that much his judgment
right sure if Kevin Smith doesn't like
he's a really nice guy like if he
doesn't like you you must be a [ __ ]
right just doesn't make any sense and
you know this but my point is that this
is fleeting it does you know like I'm 50
years old I became 50 years old I don't
know how that happened it just keeps
happening well it's funny I just turned
30 I just turned 30 on January 31st it
was the first birthday where I ever went
boo yeah I'm at my 30 [ __ ] just got a
little real I remember 30 cuz I was
dating a girl was kind of at want she
was just kind of little and not her
fault she's a little negative she's like
I already thought you already were 30
what the [ __ ] does that mean
I was like I'm telling you something's
weird and you're not even you don't even
thinking about my perspective your deal
I thought you already were 30 well you
saying I look 30 with [ __ ] what are you
saying it's a weird thing to date for
like a surface thing like oh I think the
person's older I think the person is
worth
money or think that's what it was she
was a deeply unhappy person that was
trying to diminish me not good not a
healthy relationship now it wasn't
healthy relationship period but there's
a lot of a lot of that happens in
relationships right people try to
diminish each other or they feel like
they're in a bad position of power like
they feel like they don't have the power
in the relationship so then they see
that there's possibly a vulnerability
and instead of like soothing that person
they attacked that vulnerability that's
how you know you're in a terrible toxic
their lives or struggle sure oh yeah man
that's the worst
[Applause]